know your target market if you want to
have success marketing your company then
you need to know who you're going after
and be really clear in the value that
you're providing them if you're not
clear on who your target market is then
you're going to be an ok solution for a
lot of people instead of a great
solution for a limited number of people
and it's better to have a limited number
people love you and spread the word and
take you to new markets than to just be
ok for a lot of people because you're
always going to be bested by somebody
else who's taking the time to really
listen to their audience and build
something just for them I got a great
question from a YouTube viewer love you
guys
Shona puddin to say I have a crochet
business it's doing okay but I wish it
was doing better welcome to the world of
entrepreneurship I think the reason why
I'm not doing so good is because I don't
know what my niche market is I love to
crochet but I think if I get known for
one thing in one industry my business
would grow what do you think this is
great what separates you from every
other other crochet maker out there
there's tons of people who are selling
crochet products right figure out who
loves what you're doing and find a way
to better serve their market and a great
way to do it is off a secondary interest
of yours ok so you love crochet that's
great what else do you have
do you love that's part of your being
that you do day in day out that you
passionately believe in that you could
bring to this business are you a singer
do you like to dance
dude love your kids do you love dogs you
know whatever it is there's something
else in you that you could bring to your
business and other people who are like
you who have those same interests will
connect with you and want to buy your
products does that make sense for any
entrepreneur
whatever market you're in it's
competitive whatever business you're in
there's tons of competition and often
you
competitors who have way bigger budgets
than you and can squash you in any
marketing campaign the way to stand out
the way to get known is to bring more of
yourself to your business to help you
become the expert for certain niche so
if you're selling life insurance
products
how many life insurance salesmen are
there it's ridiculous
there's tons you're selling real estate
if you're selling chairs you selling
computers you're selling crops you're
going up against people who are
well-established who are well-known who
have bigger pockets than you so the way
to stand out isn't to play their game
the way to stand out is to bring more of
yourself to your business so for example
you know say you're selling life
insurance and you love baseball you
could be the life insurance guy who
sells the baseball players that's your
niche and you focus everything you do
around them and it's genuine because you
love baseball and the baseball players
are going to connect with you better
than any other life insurance
salesperson because they feel that you
really love them and you've built
everything around them you understand
them you can talk their language you can
cater their needs same thing for this
crochet company if you love dogs and
you're creating something for dogs that
deals with crochet you're a passionate
dog owner then other people who love
their dogs will want to connect with you
over any other person to selling crochet
items because they love their dogs too
and you can speak their doggy language
and everything you do is around helping
those people with their problems so
absolutely you can stand out and this
applies for any entrepreneur bring a
secondary or third interest of yours
into your business to help you stand out
and be different because what is unique
about your company even though other
companies have more money have more
experience have more skills what's
unique about your company is you so
bring more of yourself to your business
tie your passions your interest into it
so you can figure out a better target
market who will love you respond to
everything your
and buy more of your products and
services believe those are you watching
you liked the video thumbs up below it
always makes me want to do more and
please leave a comment underneath let me
know what you think you have a question
for your business leave it below I love
seeing those come in to the best part of
my day and load up my my lentils for
breakfast I look at your comments I
respond and I love it so please leave a
comment underneath thank you so much and
I'll see you soon